c'est l'histoire d'un mec normal méloman
tranquille qui craque tout à coup et qui
sombre dans une profonde déprime c'est
l'histoire de Richard j dans mis Jones
c'est un film ça peut ne pas être un
film Nicole
cornanglois il se repose derrière cette
porte il se nourrit végétarien garde du
corps attaché de presse et photograph
veill sur lui et tout à coup Richard
apparaît plutôt faécieux décontracté en
un
mot
[Musique]
mais ne pas se fier à cette séduction
immédiate mis Jones son personnage a des
faces brillantes et d'autres bien plus
sombres obsession provocation fu devant
les
[Musique]
responsabilités son cerveau n'est pas
bien fabriqué il passe d'un extrême à
l'autre il balance entre un côté
incroyablement dépressif Eté
incroblement lumineux comme s'il était
un
dieu il est très talentueux très créatif
et cela dans tous les
[Musique]
domaines il refuse de devenir adulte il
fait un peu penser
il est toujours en train d'agir comme
les
adolescents en période de crise il veut
absolument voler pour jouer cette
situation dangereuse Richard a refusé
toute doublure ou filet de protection
courageux
non je haie le vide j'étais terrifié par
l'altitude et vous savez ce qui se passe
devant les caméras c'est le personnage
qui prend le dessus mais je peux vous
avouer que lors des premières prises de
vue j'étais véritable
[Musique]
plutôt planant Richard dans ce film fait
surmesure pour un Oscar à
l'horizon